another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the foundation dr  bright must be informed that scp-018  is not to be taunted  scp-018 is also known as the super ball  and it's a small rubber ball created by  the waymo corporation with the  frightening and destructive ability to  bounce higher and faster every single  time it bounces resulting in rampant  chaos so naturally dr bright has on  occasion gotten it out of containment to  try bouncing it around likely destroying  large amounts of foundation office  equipment and terrorizing all nearby  staff members as such his privileges  around the super ball have been revoked  and the o5 council has advised that dr  bride sticks to a simple non-anomalous  paddle ball instead